[Music]
good evening and welcome to Toco carlson
tonight I'm Mark Steyn Tucker
is off celebrating Boxing Day which is
deplorable an American of him we hope
you all enjoyed a Christmas respite from
politics but it hasn't taken long for
things to get back into full swing this
morning motivated by a story he saw here
on Fox
president Trumbull lashed out against
the FBI over the infamous salacious
Trump dosia the president tweeted Wow
dossier is bogus Clinton campaign DNC
funded dossier FBI cannot after all of
this time verify claims in dossier of
Russia Trump collusion FBI tainted and
they use this crooked Hillary pile of
garbage as the basis for going after the
Trump campaign Robin biro was
regional campaign director for Barack
Obama's presidential campaign Robin this
mi6 agent cooked up the dosia in a
couple of weeks and the FBI have been
investigating it now for a year and a
half and have been unable to confirm
anything except that one guy called
Carter page did actually get on a plane
to Russia at some point otherwise after
18 months all uncorroborated how much
time do you think the FBI should take
another two years another three years
four years five I sure hope not mark
because the taxpayers are funding this
investigation I do want to remember that
but the FBI has a responsibility to go
through all of the anything that's
presented to them as possible evidence
and leave no stone unturned that
includes this dossier it's so much of it
has been found to be not true the
veracity they say should be very much
questioned but just like any
law-enforcement official they have to
follow the leads and they have done
their due diligence due diligence and
it's turning out to not be true that's
why Hillary Clinton did not use it
that's why the Republican candidate who
initially funded this dossier did not
use it and eventually sold it to Hillary
Clinton but you know it was never used
so you're saying there's a bit of Oppo
research that the people who paid for it
didn't even bother using but has somehow
justified an 18-month investigation into
the sitting president if we flip this
around if say the GOP had found some
French spy instead of an mi6 guy to come
up with a salacious dossiers saying the
Democrat candidate is up to all kinds of
kinky shenanigans in Eastern Europe
would you be happy to have the FBI
investigate obvious nonsense for 18
months
no I would not but it does like I said
it's just the did their due diligence of
an investigating leaving no stone
unturned but I want to remind you that
what what led to this was the firing of
director Comey very unceremoniously and
and all of that there were in multiple
instances of the Russian government
trying to hack into voting systems in
several states so there were lots of
things that that triggered this it was
not just this dossier as Donald Trump
himself tried to allude to this more
wait wait a minute this Russia
investigation has been actually been
going on for longer it predates the
election so in other words why would the
Russians be trying to hack into a voting
machine in Iowa in June of 2016
mark because they have an agenda to
fulfill and disrupting our way of
democracy suits their agenda they are
our adversary make no mistake about it I
myself am a veteran Army Ranger I know
that Russia is our adversary they are
not looking out for our best interest we
have a situation here where so the only
thing that any concrete that anyone's
been able to find is that Putin paid for
a hundred grands worth of Facebook ads I
never knew speaking of someone who's not
even eligible to run I didn't know you
could steal an election for a hundred
thousand in facebook ads when your
candidate mrs. Clinton spent two-thirds
of a billion you spend two-thirds of a
billion but a guy
comes along and buys a hundred grand of
Facebook ads and boom there's snaefells
the election away is that the theory no
like I said when I think the real
problem here is when we found evidence
that they tried to actually affect the
voting machines in those states that is
a serious problem and I'm glad that the
FBI is looking into it we should all do
that we should all want the FBI to make
sure that our way of democracy is
protected and defended well they have an
oath to defend and protect our
Constitution against enemies foreign and
domestic
we have to make sure that Donald Trump
is not an enemy of the state by
colluding with Russia well taking taking
your line that Russia is a Geo political
strategic enemy of the United States
they managed to get this election
stealing racket whatever it is hacking
into voting machines in New Hampshire or
Florida or wherever up and running we've
been investigating this now for 18
months why can't the FBI wrap up an
investigation into an election campaign
in less than the two-year period between
elections mark you're not privy to that
information just like we were not privy
to all of the information and to Bill
Clinton and Watergate which ended which
ended up birthing the Monica Lewinsky
scandal we don't have all of that
information so it's impossible for and
preposterous for us right now to
speculate on why it is taking this long
they are doing their jobs they are
public servants doing their jobs and
they're becoming they're under attack on
the daily by Donald Trump who I think is
doing a PSYOP campaign because he knows
that there's more information coming and
he wants to plant a seed of doubt in the
public to me that is reprehensible
well well Robin thanks thanks thanks for
framing it as a science campaign if
you're if you're actually targeted by
the FBI I'm not I'm not sure you need
psyops or whatever protests against that
tom Fitton is the president of judicial
watch and Tom Robin was rather coy about
that but
basically this totally worthless dossier
has had an incredible life it's like a
zombie you cannot drive a stake through
this piece of garbage thing that a
foreign spy cooked up for the Democrats
it's it's it's running around like a
mechanical hair all across town has it
got any probative value as the lawyers
like to say well according to your news
organizations reporting on the testimony
of Andrew McKay the number two at the
FBI they couldn't confirm anything or he
refused to confirm anything beyond the
fact that Carter page a campaign adviser
to the Trump campaign may have traveled
to Russia right other than that there's
nothing they've been able to confirm but
we have what we have been able to
confirm is that the authors of the Trump
dossier were Clinton campaign vendors
and they were working with the Obama
Justice Department and the Obama FBI and
the FBI the Obama of the Obama
administration was the leadership there
was a vehemently anti Trump it's now
evident and they laundered this campaign
document into the Justice Department and
FBI and it may have been used to spy on
the Trump campaign and it still made it
still may be being used by Robert
Mueller
so you know through degree dossier the
dossier is still being used by Mueller
it's a real ethical concern because of
it because of where it came from
no III agree with you on on that Tom I
mean in a sense it's a bit like what in
Hollywood Alfred Hitchcock used to call
the MacGuffin
it's like used as the pretext to set the
game afoot in other words it had no
value as all Poe research to Hillary
Clinton but it had value to the
government the outgoing government in in
getting them into a position where they
could surveil their political opponents
that's the conspiracy theory and it gets
even worse for mrs. Clinton because what
happened is that mrs. Clinton used her
law firm her campaigns law firm as a
cutout to spend money on this fusion GPS
Stasi effort who
went to Russia supposedly to talk to
intelligence people and intelligence
sources in Russia so yet the Clinton
campaign spending money to send people
to Russia to find dirt on on Donald
Trump and Donald Trump's the wonder one
under investigation on collusion and to
me this is a political investigation it
was designed by never Trump errs anti
Trump errs whatever you want to call it
James Comey obviously did not like
President Trump and the leaked
information in order to get this
appointment of Robert Mueller and it's
it's just gone downhill from there now
we found out the top FBI agent under
Mueller in terms of counterintelligence
was a never Trump er the number - Andrew
Weissman the number two prosecutor on
his team attended Hillary Clinton's
election night poker night and was
sending friendly emails to Sally Yates
as she thwarted know that law at the
Justice Department that's a Obama
holdover that's actually incredible Tom
thank you for that